[Musica]
il problema della prevenzione dei rischi
non solo sismica e che parlerebbe
parlarne prima soprattutto attuare prima
la prevenzione che avvenga l'ennesima
tragedia e purtroppo sono sta accadendo
in questo momento ne parlano tanti poi
vedremo se le parole seguiranno anche
dei fatti
diciamo politicamente la prevenzione
paga poco nel senso che fa sì che non si
vedano i risultati per i risultati sono
i disastri che non sono avvenute però
non possiamo neanche accusare diciamo
solo le istituzioni di non
a far nulla perché la mancanza di
prevenzione soprattutto in paesi come
l'italia è dovuta al fatto che
l'opinione pubblica non percepisce i
rischi e quando parliamo di rischi
dobbiamo ricordarci particolare nel caso
di terremoto che entrano in gioco
diverse figure che spesso comunicano
poco fra di loro per esempio i sismologi
cioè il rischio è composta almeno da
pericolosità un abilità ed esposizione
sull'inter parametri la pericolosità di
un movimento del terreno che ci
attendiamo ed è compito dei sismologi
definirla la vulnerabilità passiamo agli
ingegneri che pare un po poco i
sismologi purtroppo è la capacità delle
costruzioni di resistere a quel
movimento e l'esposizione in senso lato
la
le conseguenze il valore della struttura
che andiamo a considerare pensiamo museo
sono le opere d'arte ma pensiamo che qui
siamo in area colpita dal nel 1693 il
terremoto della val di noto che sapete
quante vittime 60.000 almeno fece a
catania c'è anche per esempio se succede
qualcosa un impianto come quello di
priolo ball fatto
e qual è la situazione a livello
italiano e un gravissimo per l'assenza
di prevenzione per decenni cioè noi
questo è un dato ormai ufficiale e sta
negli atti della camera dei deputati dal
2012 seguito da proposte di legge che
poi sono rimaste proposte come purtroppo
è d'uso in questo paese abbiamo da 70
all 80 per cento e costruito italiano un
po dappertutto e non che non è in grado
di reggere ai terremoti a cui potrebbe
venire soggetto e probabilmente sarà
soggetto prima o poi
poi si può discutere sul primo poi ma
probabilmente lo sarà perché già
avvenuti un dato su cui si può discutere
sul primo sul po il ban non molto sul
fatto che questo magari ai nostri
discendenti possa accadere e qual è
questo numero cosi alto è
particolarmente preoccupante deriva da
diversi fattori 1 il fatto che durante
gli anni si è cominciato
si è classificato sismicamente si dice
cioè se il territorio italiano sempre di
più è classificato vuol dire definito
sismica una certa zona che prima non lo
era
oppure aumentata a livello di
pericolosità che si attribuisce
pericolosità se è relativa al movimento
dei terreni 2 l'evoluzione normativa 3
purtroppo il fatto che molti progetti
sono buoni la realizzazione pessima e
questo è dovuto all'assenza di corretto
i controlli per tanto tempo delle
costruzioni ne ho viste di strutture
anche che sarebbe dovuta essere ottime
anche qui in sicilia devo dire dove non
vengo che la prima volta invece non lo
so e l'ultimo fatto ci si è messo anche
ci si sono messe le istituzioni
rinviando il l'entrata in vigore
obbligatorio di alcune normative per per
anni normative del 2003 come per esempio
l'analisi della vulnerabilità sismica ed
edifici pubblici penso alle scuole che
mi interessano particolarmente di
ospedale che dovrebbero rimanere
operativi ma la scuola ci pensa ancora
di più perché contiene il futuro di una
comunità e noi questo lo dobbiamo
garantire
ecco non entra ovviamente nei dettagli
ma quel 70 per cento lo ricavate
semplicemente combinando quei dati di
evoluzione alla classificazione sismica
del territorio di cui parlavo prima
se pensate che nel 1980 l'anno del
terremoto dei pini era classificato
sismicamente solo il 25 per cento del
territorio italiano mentre ora siamo al
70 pensate che per anni si è continua si
è cominciato a classificare sismicamente
nel nel regno d'italia per i borboni
nello prossimità vari prima solo dopo il
terremoto di messina e reggio calabria
del 1908
allora uno dice che faccio
aspetto che il buon dio spero che il
buon dio non faccia nulla no intanto e
ball dio non è il buon dio che decide
probabilmente è la terra
poi abbiamo il modo per difenderci cioè
dire succede quindi speriamo che non si
succederanno errore noi abbiamo tutte le
tecnologie anche in italia per
difenderci con due strade anche
combinabili una rendere robusta una
struttura in modo che resiste e l'altra
inserire particolare sistemi non posso
entrare nel dettaglio per questi di
tempo come l'isolamento sismico che un
filtro del terremoto cioè come se uno
fosse su un terreno ghiacciato coi
pattini no il terreno si muove voi
rispetta le stelle state ferme quindi
non è proprio così
però in realtà isolare vuol dire
praticamente disconnettere il movimento
della struttura rispetto al terreno non
sempre è possibile soprattutto per le
strutture esistenti quindi stiamo
parlando di tecnologie applicabili sia
al nuovo nuovo facilissimamente ma anche
alle esistenze con particolare fortezze
se non riusciamo a fare isolamento
sismica abbiamo per esempio la
dissipazione di energia perché per
isolare la struttura è vero che rimane
ferma rispetto alle stelle ma si muove
rispetto al terreno quindi ha bisogno di
tanto spazio lateralmente non sempre
questo c'è soprattutto in edifici
esistenti
la dissipazione consiste invece nel
mettere all'interno della struttura
degli apparecchi particolari che
concentrano su se stessi e trasformano
in calore questo vuol dire dissipare
l'energia del terremoto trasmette la
struttura stessa e quindi fanno quel
lavoro che altrimenti la struttura
dovrebbe fare danneggiandosi o al limite
colasante quando parliamo di isolamento
non parliamo di casenuove primi al
vecchio per scrive l'isolamento sismico
un po rozzo del tempio di diana e teso a
in altri paesi questa tecnologia l'idea
è nata
tanto tempo fa adesso la sappiamo
applicare me li abbiamo diversi sistemi
più utilizzato qui vedete una doppia
applicazione sistema di rinforzo sopra e
isolamento sismico con degli isolatori
in gomma ci sono anche altre tipologie
sotto non sempre basta per adeguare una
struttura isolare perché quello che
rimane sopra è vero che un po
alleggerito dalle forze sismiche però
rimane pur sempre può rimanere pur
sempre troppo debole
ormai ne abbiamo tantissime di strutture
i dati non siano più aggiornati ma nel
2013 eravamo a oltre 23 mila
applicazioni in oltre 30 paesi del mondo
di sistemi antisismici compresi per
esempio ospedali e comprese anche opere
d'arte abbiamo vicino sono a reggio
calabria i bronzi di riace che hanno
l'isolamento sismico da anni e l'italia
non è messa assolutamente male perché è
il quarto paese al mondo per
applicazione legislatore di isolatori
sismici agli edifici e abbiamo
cominciato prima dei giapponesi degli
americani ad applicare poi siamo stati
fermi per anni per vicissitudini di qui
pro bono pacis non parlo ma i giapponesi
adesso ci hanno surclassato per numero
però l'idea è nata tra i primi paesi in
italia quindi basta dire una nuova
applicazione giapponese se si vede un
edificio con isolamento sismico
i giapponesi hanno applicazioni
addirittura anche stupide devo dire io
sono d'accordo anche pari ai grattacieli
a cui non serve l'isolamento sismico
andrebbe meglio la dissipazione hanno
delle applicazioni molto interessanti e
molto più serie di quelle per esempio
fatte a l'aquila i cosiddetti terreni
artificiali artificio ground che sono
delle grandi piattaforme su cui si
possono mettere interi isolati
lo stiamo pensando per la ricostruzione
del centro italia se sarà possibile anno
applicazione anche a beni museali
questo si distingue da un giappone
insomma noi abbiamo tanto patrimonio
storico artistico loro mi hanno un po
meno sai meno però il museo le cui basi
e che non è antico però visto il nome
architetto è un edificio considerato da
non toccare neppure le fondazioni è
stato sotto fondato e isolato e poi
anche addirittura applicazione casetta
in legno li ha senso all'aquila ne aveva
molto meno ecco venendo e patrimonio
artistico purtroppo va bene isolarlo
estate ma se gli crolla il tetto addosso
che loro isola fare allora non abbiamo
manco un museo con l'isola protetto da
isolamento significa e una grande
discussione che in giro in atto adesso
ne abbiamo in vari paesi del mondo stati
uniti i musei nuovi sono tutti con
isolamento sismico li hanno adeguato
appunto isolamento sismico ha detto che
l'isolamento significa può essere
adeguato come i principi di
conservazione un po all'acqua di rosa
anche edifici storici come la gran parte
dei municipi della california
ecco una cosa che vorrei citare un
esempio
queste tecniche non sono dimostrate come
efficacia solamente attraverso analisi e
prove sperimentali ma anche da veri
terremoti ne abbiamo tanti ormai che
hanno colpito edifici protetti da teste
tecniche e mostro solo uno terremoto
accaduto in cina in un'area colpita già
cinque anni prima dal tema da un grande
terremoto di vincent e fece in migliaia
di vittime
appena ricostruita nonostante la pena
ricostruita 75 per cento degli edifici
sono stati danneggiati sono crollati
e però ecco c'è una dimostrazione in
questo posto di una delle tante
dimostrazioni edificate dell'isolamento
sismico per esempio in ospedale come ho
detto a me non basta che l'ospedale non
crolli dopo il terremoto deve rimanere
operativo perché deve
e curare i feriti ecco questo è un
ospedale con due corpi di fabbrica
fondati convenzionalmente ed uno con
isolamento sismico questi sono i due
convenzionali ricostruiti appena non
crollati ma assolutamente in disabili
per lo scopo che aveva diciamo questa
struttura e questa è quella con
isolamento sismico rimasto l'unico
ospedale della zona a rimanere o
completamente operativo dopo terremoto
pensate che quando ci fu il terremoto
del pollino
gli ospedali normanna è andato fuori uso
con un terremoto di magnitudo 5 quando
li si devono attendere ben di più più di
sette e la magnitudo è logaritmica
quindi un grado di magnitudine più vuol
dire dieci volte tanto di accelerazione
32 di energia per in italia abbiamo
applicazioni molto importanti ormai ne
abbiamo più di 400 già un paio d'anni fa
e abbiamo per esempio il centro della
protezione civile di foligno che a sette
edifici che un isolamento sismico e
adesso è stato molto utile è rimasto
operativo anche misure strumentazioni
siamo riusciti a ottenere tutta una
serie di dati molto importanti
una nota per gli architetti queste
tecniche sono molto utili anche agli
architetti perché permettono delle forme
strutturali che altrimenti non possono
essere realizzate con fondazioni di tipo
convenzionale e nessuno pensi che
parliamo di tecniche utilizzabili solo
per di grandi edifici strategici
pubblici e nominato le scuole a cui
tengo particolarmente nominato gli
ospedali ma anche gli edifici normali
qui a messina
questo era il più alto edificio italiano
più di otto piani
almeno fino a qualche tempo fa plastiche
ce n'era un altro in costruzione forse
più alto protetto con isolamento sismico
con delle difficoltà perché a fianco ci
stanno alcuni edifici assai re
chi di cui non conosciamo la
vulnerabilità ricostruzione ci si parla
tanto allora il castello di gemona o
collaudato in due edifici ricostruiti a
40 anni dal televoto ricostruiti non
vuol dire difatti come erano prima dire
ricostruisco come dov'era e vabbè non
dico cosa è capito cosa voglio dire sì
forse dov'era abbiamo questa è un
edificio a fabriano si è comportato
ottimamente contrariamente a tutti di
una palazzina al primo intervento in
europa di isolamento in sottofondazione
è costato molto meno che riparare in
modo convenzionale
ecco vedete ricostruire a gemona la
torre dell'orologio è stata ricostruita
con all'interno un telaio in acciaio con
dissipatori non è che si potesse fare
come prima
esattamente come prima i materiali sì ma
certamente la tecnica possiamo
intervenire anche sotto i beni
monumentali questo ovviamente costa
si tratta di scegliere dire ricostruisco
il centro della grandissima balla
bisogna scegliere quelle strutture che
vale la pena ricostruire ci sono i
metodi per esempio infilando sotto dei
tubi sotto sotto sotto rispetti tutti i
principi di conservazione ci sono già
dei progetti
purtroppo non ha ancora capito e poi i
grandi capolavori adesso si sta molto
discutendo del david di michelangelo sia
avvenuto paura ai toscani
forse anche giustamente che la crisi
sismica in atto possa evolvere anche
verso nord e non solo verso est della
protezione sismica del david di
michelangelo che è molto mal messo
perché ha le caviglie estremamente
fatturare fatturate ed è stata l'aperto
tra l'altro inclinato eccetera eccetera
insomma questo non regge a terremoti ben
più piccoli di quelli già accaduti o che
terremoti già avvenuti nell'area
fiorentina
vogliamo che mi succeda quello che è
successo all'estate dell'aquila
intervista nella via proposito
precedente museo della tela tutte rotte
allora tecnologie
lo dicevo le abbiamo che abbiamo
disponibili si tratta solo di applicarle
a san giuliano abbiamo avuto morti tutti
i bambini di 6 anni tutti è in cina
hanno avuto 900 morti per per il crollo
di una scuola in emilia io sono di
bologna
dobbiamo ringraziare che il terremoto
non sa farlo non è avvenuto per esempio
di domenica che tutte le chiese se ne
sono state fortemente danneggiate
abbiamo gli impianti a rischio noi non
abbiamo quelli nucleare non abbiamo
quelli chimici a priolo ci sono solo 6 3
serbatoi protetti dall isolamento
sismico è però un'ultima parola e poi
concludo ricordiamo si di smetterla di
considerare antico tutto ciò che ha più
di cinquant'anni
tutto ciò non è tutto uguale al colosseo
c'è l'antico e c'è il vecchio il vecchio
va demolito e ricostruito in maniera
sicura purtroppo questi sono messaggi
che lancia da tanto tempo io e degli
altri non siamo riusciti a cambiare
questo paese
io spero che voi la tv fa
[Applauso]